citizens of the reject nation greg here
john good morning to you good morning
how are you i am so excited right now
ladies and gentlemen i saw my favorite
band perform live last night so i got
12 hours of sleep to get up here half
hour six in the morning to do this and
it's gonna be worth it cause that teaser
trick i feel like people are sleeping on
andor when that teaser looks awesome
that's already been greenlit for a
season two meaning they have a lot of
faith in this leave a like use the force
to
leave a like it doesn't take much force
so do it anyhoo let's see what's going
on in this trailer
[Music]
beautiful
already beautiful
to steal from the empire
[Music]
so eerie you just walk in like you
belong
they're so proud of themselves
so fat and satisfied
they can't imagine
not someone like me
who would ever get inside their house
cassian
the empire is choking us so slowly
we're starting not to notice
what i'm asking is this
wouldn't you rather give it all
to something real
damn this looks so beautiful yeah
i need all the heroes i can get he's the
header figure
for the greater good
oh [ __ ] call it what you will saw let's
call it
there's fermenting out there some
pockets of fermenting
[Music]
you're in my neck
are you a fish
or are you a thief
you're slipping
i'm not sleeping
i've just been hiding for too long
oh [ __ ]
well as long as everyone thinks i'm an
irritation
there's a good chance they'll miss what
i'm really doing what are you really
doing playing both sides
helping the rebellion evolution looks
like
we'll be televised
i'm tired of losing a disney fuss
three episode premiere is it september
21st that was august yeah i thought it
was the end of august and i thought it
was a two episode from here that must be
really enthused about this man i heard
there's like 12 episodes in this i guess
we missed some updates here yeah that's
some big stuff yeah i mean the main talk
of this trailer lately has been like how
beautiful it looks and yeah it does look
beautiful looks like a combination of
actual on-set location shots and then a
combination combined with they have to
be using that volume technology as which
has become so synonymous with making
these now especially when the
mandalorian came out there's something
about it that just feels so tangible and
feels so real and i really like that
we're going to be getting like a lot of
at least the trailer seems like we're
going to be getting a lot of mon mothma
at the the early days you know you see
you're talking with the coruscant senate
council and that she's placating to the
empire so it seems right right but she's
actually slowly helping the rebellion
out but one part that struck me is
rather interesting i think the character
what is this selling skarsgard's
character i think it's lutheran there's
that moment between him and mon mothma
they're exchanging what looks like
pleasantries hey i don't know much about
this show but i'm like wait are are they
working like
together by this point in the show they
both look like they're living the
luxurious you know political uh empire
lifestyle yeah but then when the way
they greeted each other it's kind of
seemed like oh i don't know if they know
that they really want to take down the
empire
so don't think that i'm just actually
resting on my laurels showing the empire
life i really do want to resist
a cover to maintain because like yeah
diego luna looks awesome in this show i
really liked him in rogue one and i
really i i really like rogue one i know
rogue one kind of gets crapped on for
that but i think rogue one's great
because yeah as gorgeous as this looks
and as i love that music in here
what eerie ticking time clock music just
feels like there's something percolating
under the surface that's just gonna come
to the rise and i like that it's like
this ghostly haunting like
i don't know how
they are haunted by a lot of the the
traumas that the empire has inflicted on
them especially a character like cassian
andor and everything he lost as a kid
and has grown up into this now he's
described it as like a refugee story
you're watching him find his place in
this rebellion and look for hope in the
darkest of times like this is like
top-tier empire work right here you know
um this is when their full formation and
at their strongest this definitely looks
like a star war and it's funny because
you know hearing people ponder and
contemplate the current state of star
wars what star wars should become and
where it should go feeling like an
actual war is taking place with real
fallout you know like wars displace
people and yeah diego luna has described
this as a refugee story and that really
feels tangible from this trailer it's
like yeah you have these characters who
are in these more privileged positions
you know doing their double agent duty
in such a way but you're also looking at
the people who are bearing the biggest
brunt of an intergalactic conflict like
this and so i love the way that they
infuse perspective into a lot of the
shots they're going for and it looks
like they're even further going down
that rabbit hole of making everything
look like it is some kind of sci-fi
illustration uh but also using that not
only to go to make you go wow beautiful
but to make you go oh wow this is really
harsh and harrowing injecting a certain
level of kind of grit immediacy into the
star wars formula while maintaining all
those aesthetics with so many different
characters to focus on in this world so
many different spin-offs and things i
really like the tone we're getting here
and and while it is like kind of a meme
of current uh you know franchise ips and
what not having like a dark and gritty
franchise or something that has comments
about you know war and the fallout from
that i don't know this seems like a very
appropriate place for that and i'm
excited to hopefully get some new life
in terms of the characters that we're
seeing i always hope that one of these
shows they ride so much on the things we
know already and this seems like a cool
opportunity to do some of that but also
expound and uh yeah show us a different
glimpse into you know this intergalactic
conflict yeah
and and and stellen skarsgard definitely
dies uh
what'd you guys think about the andor
trailer i'm excited for it it looks
great refreshing different paintless
cinematic hey
michael linden you've been with us for
so long you have shown commitment
loyalty love pledge your duty to the
empire of the reject nation and i trust
you with everything we
we have to offer i just don't know as
many people as loyal as you so thank you
for being
a loyalist occultist a zealot
everything about washington that we love
about a follower of the reject nation
you
take care of all of europe for us
and make sure all of our shipments and
goods get transported properly and are
delivered to the right people and don't
forget to collect the tax yes on the
local townsfolk protect our exports our
spice
trade
you found the star wars reference thank
you
no problem i was searching this whole
time patron dash
[Music]